hello everyone and welcome to game three
of the world chairs championship 2021
it's the only punch with the white
pieces against the magnus cards and
they've already played two games uh both
games ended in a draw and everyone's
been wondering whether we're gonna see a
repetition of the sort of an
anti-martial we've had in game one uh
where instead of the
martial attack with c3d five white went
uh h3 but now it's a little bit of a
different story but it's uh kind of why
we're here uh because players will play
something and then of course uh
themselves and their seconds will try to
improve on that try and look for missed
opportunities uh you know the deadly
ideas in in what
already happened in the previous game
and try to employ it uh in the in the
next game where nipple or magnus will
have the white pieces and this is
something that was attempted here so
let's check it out what happened but
before we check it out a quick detour to
a few photos so let's just uh check out
this photo
so this is the beginning of game three
magnus arriving and you can already see
that the handshake has begun well before
magnus actually reached the table so
it's hard to say uh when he even uh
started doing the handshake it could be
like maybe three steps back i mean it
could be
could be even uh you know halfway
through but as you can see still no eye
contact magnus probably staring at
nipple's palm and nipple very much
fixated on magnus's
uh maurice there uh this time looking at
magnus that could be very dangerous as
we've seen in the past but uh he's you
know uh he's uh
uh living the the wildlife and um
that's all there is to the handshake
still nothing spectacular on the photos
many many corporate logos here and uh
well as usual if you guys uh can spot
anything interesting about the photos do
let me know in the comments uh i would
like to point out that nipples nippo's
coffee or whatever he has looks very
very futuristic you can see it's uh you
know
sort of like something that you would
see in a star trek episode it it looks
very very flashy so i i imagine that's
coffee in there but it could also be
some herbal tea maybe earl grey uh you
know like picard is having who who knows
but okay uh going going forward here we
have the first move being made the first
move was made by anastasia mishkina a
former russian tennis player and she
played d4 on the first move but nipple
was not very interested in that he
wanted to play a real game and he of
course retracted that d4 move and uh
well continued with something else but
we'll get back to that
and now let's check out the game uh so
nipple with the white pieces retracts
this d for move and plays e4 so we will
probably see what we've already seen in
game one magnus goes e5 we have knight
to f3 knight to c6 and now bishop to b5
the real opus is on the board uh we have
a6 morpheus defense bishop to a4 and now
knight to f6 so everything the same as
in game one we have castles bishop to e7
and rook to e1 uh we have b5 challenging
the light square bishop here on a4
bishop back to b3 and here magnus
castles and now uh here in game one we
were wondering will we see a martial
attack with c3 and d5 but in game one we
saw h3 sort of the anti-martial but here
we have the actual anti-marshal with a4
this is known as the anti-martial
variation so white is trying to avoid
complications that arise after c3 and d5
although it's not excluded that we will
see a martial attack in one of the games
but um as you can bet your life that
magnus is extremely prepared for that so
i don't know if there is a a good reason
for for nipple to even attempt such a
thing uh and here as this is still all
very very much standard theory i would
just like to point out to this photo now
you can see that nipple is away from the
board staring at magnus and pretty much
uh as soon as nipple makes a move he
leaves the board and he is very rarely
seen at the table so most of the photos
of nipple are actually of him away from
the table you can see that that gentle
look that he's giving magnus hoping for
him to blunder
but that's pretty much all he can do uh
you know when it's not his move
but okay here we have a for the
anti-martial variation like i said h3
was played in game one here we have a
deviation from game one bishop to b7 and
now d3 we have d6 and knight beat to d2
so all very standard stuff nothing out
of the ordinary here usually black will
go with something like knight a5 attack
the bishop white will go back and black
will uh
go for this c5 push as the knight now
made way for the pawn but here we have
rook to e8 again very standard idea the
bishop has to come to f8
then the rook will gain some
more activity along the e file and also
the bishop on f8 will be used very
nicely to defend the g7 pawn knight to
f1 by nippo going for that knight to e3
or knight to g3 depending on what white
plays with h6 and bishop to d2 we have
bishop back to f8 that's how you play
this and now knight to e3 and here we
have knight to e7 interestingly uh this
position was reached in a game uh in in
the 90s between uh anakili karpov and
the effing geller where knight the d7
was played carpool was able to win that
game but now as we do have uh uh the uh
you know
the engines uh we know that we can just
listen to them and the uh hence knight
to e7 uh we have c4 striking against
this b5 pawn in magnus's all right i i
don't mind trading my b pawn for a c
pawn so b captures on c4 and now there
is one game in the database where bishop
captures and see where four was played
but here we have knight captures on c4
by nipple and it is now as of move 15
that we have a completely new game and
now one would expect as magnus already
played knight to e7 that he wants to go
knight to g6
but no he instead goes back knight to c6
he wants to have some more um
pressure here against this d4
square as you are expecting nipple to
play d4 at some point it's a backwards
spawn you do not want this weakness on
d3 forever so it's a it's a pretty sure
bet we have rook to c1 nipple puts a
rook on the nice semi-open c file and
magnus plays a5
uh grabbing more space on the queen side
now knight to b4 can be played also
bishop to a6 you've made room for that
and all in all you pervade uh prevent
white from
executing a5 anytime soon so here we
have bishop to c3 nipple puts his
bishops on this beautiful diagonal or
rather these beautiful diagonals and
magnus now needs to find uh how to
counter this so of course he says all
right those bishops are extremely
powerful
i will counter them and he goes bishop
to c8 so he wants to play bishop to e6
encounter the bishop on b3
and now as magnus allowed it nipple
plays d4 and uh gets rid of his
backwards d3 pawn so magnus captures we
have e captures on d4 knight captures
knight captures and now queen captures
with his powerful bishop queen battery
but magnus is ready for this as the
bishop is already on f8 guarding the g7
square so the knight can freely move if
needed we have bishop to e6 by magnus
and now
h3 uh gaining control of that g4 square
getting some breeding room for the king
we have c6 magnus also wants to play d5
he does not want any backwards pawns uh
and now bishop to c to nipple shifts the
attention of this bishop to this
diagonal now and magnus executes this
central thrust with the d5 so d5 and now
what do you do here well you could say
all right let's trade on d5 and this is
now definitely equal because you know
even without checking anything that if
you capture here that's not going to
bring you anything good so nepo has to
try and create some imbalances
in the position he does have the white
pieces so
it is expected of him uh he goes e5
challenges the knight on f6 and now
magnus captures in c4 we have d captures
in c4 queen captures on d8 we have a
queen trait of course this rook is stuck
here guarding the a5 pawn so magnus has
to capture with the e8 rook so rook e
captures on d8 and now uh we have uh e
captures on f6 grabbing that knight and
now of course you do not want to capture
here and allow something like bishop
captures on f6 magnus just goes bishop
to b4 and this is another fine example
of just tucking your bishop in for later
use now the bishop comes into b4 and of
course if uh the the bishop is captured
then black will get a very nice spawn
chain here so f captures in g7 magnus
has to capture on c3 we have b captures
on c3 and now king captures an uh g7 and
now we have this uh end game uh where
both players have two rooks and the
bishop and the uh number of pawns is uh
the same five ones each but if you look
at the position a nipple has three pawn
islands whereas magnus has four pawn
islands here the a pawn island the c
pawn island the f n to the h and also
his c pawns are doubled so it's hard to
evaluate the position but if you had to
pick a side you would say all right i'll
take white here so came to f1 nipple
starts bringing the king into the game
we have rook a to b8 of course magnus
puts a rook on the nice open b file
broke the b1 nipple counters that rook
and now king to f6 magnus also improves
the activity of his king
we have rook captures on v8 rook
captures and now rook to b1 offering a
trade of another pair of rooks and we
have captures and captures and now we
have this end game now where it's a
bishop against the bishop the bishops
are of the uh same color so uh
usually
that can be exploited very well but here
it's the exact same amount of pawns yes
the magnus does have four pawn islands
but it's very hard to make something uh
of this because as you can see carlson
has the a5 pawn and the h6 spawn on dark
squares and these spawns that are on
light squares they're very close to the
king and the bishop so they can easily
defend them so it's not easy for nipple
to find any targets and you can be sure
that these spawns are going to dark
squares very very soon so basically the
only pawn that will remain on a light
square is the c4 pawn and that's very
nicely protected by the bishop so not a
lot for nipple to do here we have king
e5 king the e2 and now f5 by magnus we
have bishop to c2 like i said there's
not all that much for nipple to do here
uh
he can
well pretty much just repeat moves we
have f4 nicely placing this pawn on a
dark square bishop to b1 and now c5 and
now you can see that all of carlson's
spawns are on dark squares except the
pawn on c4 which is on a light square
but very well defended by the bishop
here so not a lot to do nipple just
repeats bishop to c2 we have bishop to
d7 and now f3
we have king back to f6 h for now by
nipple uh and the king back to e5 we
have king to f2 and now king to f6 came
to e2 we have king to e5 and king to f2
and it was in this position on mu 41 as
soon as time control was reached that
the players agreed to a draw as there
really isn't anything you can you can
try here it's a dead draw and the
players of course uh know this so nippo
did not get all that much uh from his uh
game with the white pieces here in game
three of the world chess championship he
did try this a4 idea instead of h3
although there was a lot more poison in
the game uh when the h3 variation was
employed here with a4 you see just how
well prepared magnus is and he
completely neutralized everything nipple
had to throw at him
but there really wasn't all that much to
throw here so uh that's not really gonna
work and magnus really showed it this
game uh we'll see what nipple prepares
in game five but now uh in the next game
in game four will be uh very interesting
to see will we have a repetition of the
catalan from game two uh what will
happen because there was so much poison
in that game so i i don't know if uh
even though if they worked uh on on the
variations you know the the entire day
or the entire second day uh will they
even repeat it because it's very very
deadly but it will be interesting to see
uh if they go for it or or they choose
something else uh so yeah that's the
game three was a fairly quick draw hope
you guys enjoyed that
i would like to thank a happy birthday
my tom derelo buburus on business coach
academy.com and hotty family for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it uh as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
world church championship until it ends
uh see you soon and uh have an excellent
rest of your day